like the perfect reaction for this type  of movie though right um i'm being told  that we actually have to wrap up i just  have one last question for colin if  that's okay um when you started uh  applying makes certainly as an actor and  especially playing  can you stop can you not do that and  don't interrupt me no my character takes  a great deal of  inspiration from the batman yeah yeah  we're we're almost done we're almost  done just don't interrupt just i'm  willing to risk embarrassment i'm trying  to interview everyone you can't be the  center of attention all the time paul  dano you are a nightmare okay on the  press jungle i hear stories all the time  from my colleagues together  stop stop  stop  stop  well uh the batman isn't it's in  theaters